mississippi beat kentucky in overtime
lost their first game
to uh the fourth ranked florida gators
he's lane kiffin who uh has alabama
coming to town coach how you feeling
today great dan
how are we doing uh i'm doing fine
because i'm basically in my own little
bubble here but uh
how are you guys surviving all of this
with uh you know all the protocols you
have to go through
uh we're doing well our players have
done a great job you know we had a
number of cases early on
um and then uh i think three weeks in a
row now
uh we've been perfect and that's a lot
of people that's not just like the nfl i
mean you got
you got hundreds of people you're
testing throughout your whole building
so um
our guys have done a great job how has
this affected how you've prepared your
team or coaching your team
uh it hasn't much now early on in camp
you know we were really worried because
we were getting people so
changing positions teaching people
multiple spots and things like that
but hopefully we can stay stay how we
are now i know and i just mentioned
what's happening in the nfl
and the nfl has all the money do all the
testing and they're still
very vulnerable here how vulnerable do
you feel
college football is this season yeah
we're way worse on that obviously
because first off we're not dealing with
professional adults
so you know we're dealing with kids that
you know go to parties go out on
town and they're college kids so
it's very difficult you know because you
look around people say oh well
they just social distance there oh
hardly anybody's social distancing i
mean i see pictures all the time or if
you drive around
you know you know there's a lot of
people out there adults that act like
this isn't even going on let alone kids
what do you tell your uh your players
about nick saban in alabama
uh we just talked to them about you know
that you know this is
you know best team in the country
probably coach's best team he's ever had
you know no holes in it so you gotta
play perfect you gotta
prepare really well um and do everything
right in order to have a chance to win
last time you corresponded with him you
text him
uh he doesn't text so that that doesn't
work um
he told me he just got email lane
there's no way he's doing that well
somebody
somebody is doing it for him but he said
due to covet he decided he was going to
get email
he just got emailed wow what's that
twitter when's the last time you talked
to him uh
we were um at s before covent we were at
uh head coaches meeting
um for the sec um and and talked to him
there
but you you're going against alabama but
you're going against nick saban
right well i don't play and he doesn't
play so
um we we we have better chances if that
was the case i think
well i don't know he's a former
defensive back so he might be able to
cover you
yeah he's in it's like
[Laughter]
i was told i'm really worried about
coach you know he's elderly now you know
oh no
[Music]
stay safe and not having that home field
advantage how big is i mean you have
home field but
is it an advantage here no it's not um
that's changed and we went on the road
last week and um
very different you know we were at
alabama and lost two regular season
games they were both to ole miss one was
right here
um and the stadium was rocking that day
and so uh that's too bad we don't have
that
and uh you know when you start to look
at all those players that you were
around at alabama who's the best player
that you were around when you were at
alabama i think that's a coin toss
between
derek henry and amari cooper um it was
awesome those guys both had
you know heisman blitnikoff
record-breaking ears that still stand
um but they're like the hardest working
guys on the team too
with no ego that's why they're so great
just really cool florida kids that came
up to bama to be great speaking of
florida how good is that quarterback
really good but not as good as that
tight end geez
we don't card we're double covering him
yeah you seem wide open coach yeah and
we were in double coverage and he's wide
open
what's tougher to coach in the sec or
recruit in the sec
i think recruit you know it's just
non-stop
you know if you aren't non-stop
recruiting um don't matter all the
all the ex's owed you can draw up you
know i know it's an old saying but this
thing's about jimmy and joe's in this
conference and always has been and so
it's why you see totally different
styles work offensively defensively the
other day none of it works without
players
so you got to have good players and when
you don't you get exposed really fast
and you see that give me your favorite
recruiting story
uh i don't know that i oh uh
um i was an assistant i was recruiting
coordinator for pete carroll
so i would plan the trips where we were
going to go and you know had the top
recruits in
around the country that i had to go
recruiting so tim tebow i was on tivo
and i was kind of like i used to think
we could sign everybody you know no
matter what so
um me and otron always said that we'll
go get him no matter what coach so
i go down there ct voting so i fly coach
across the country
you know we get there we start driving
he's like where are we like we're in the
middle of
nowhere out in jacksonville he's like
why is this kid going to come to us like
coach
we're going to get him we're going to
get him and we pull up to the farm that
they live on
and there's a florida gator mailbox
[Laughter]
we used to walk in there's a florida
gator mat right there and uh
turns me he's like he's like why are you
wasting my time right now
uh and we stayed for like four hours
great family his dad bob and everybody
and brother were there and so
um he goes oh that was a really
enjoyable four hours um so
where's the next quarterback we're going
to try to get oh god
did you think you had a chance i did he
came up for official visit
i think we beat ucla that day or
something and a big win and uh took him
out that night to the beach
uh to dinner and um you know i used to
kind of think we're gonna get everybody
so
um maybe tim tim says we came in second
place that counts
did coach o advise you not to take the
ole miss john
no not at all um uh you know
he's seen this place you know five years
ago they won the sugar bowl here so
um it's not like we're trying to do
something that's never happened before
you know and so you know they've played
well like i said they beat us twice at
alabama the only team to do that
have you been to a tailgate there at ole
miss
i have not and they don't have them that
is shut down
oh a lot of people were looking forward
to that you know family friends that had
never been
here and had heard about it so the grove
is shut down also
yeah you guys always win the tailgate
you may not win the sec but you win the
sec tailgate
i have heard that yeah well have fun
this weekend
and uh you got any surprises for uh
coach saban
um i don't know we're gonna need
everyone that we can i think we're like
50 point underdogs you're not 50 point
underdogs
well dan i average score is like 63 to
13 the last
first bind so that's 50 points so
mclovin would you check and see
what kind of underdogs mississippi is to
alabama yeah he's right it's 50
something right now no i'm scared no
no it's not 50. if you
try like 24 and a half or something it's
23 and a half coach
yeah entertainment purposes only 23 and
a half
i'm taking oh i'm taking mississippi in
the 23 and a half
all right let's go i don't i'm allowed
i i can talk about this you can't talk
about this no t
take the money line it'd probably be
like plus plus 1 million
so i'm taking mississippi straight up
against alabama the money line
let's go all righty all right if i win
i'll share the money with you
okay i don't think that's legal no okay
i won't do that then
uh thanks coach good to talk to you all
right dan have a good week
that's lane kiffin